salut les menthe à l'eau je rentre à
l'instant même d'une date de tournée et
pigeonne me dire tiens c'est peut-être
la bonne opportunité pour faire pas
vraiment un blog mais plutôt voici ce
qui se passe quand je passe en tournée
durant deux minutes chrono
donc je vais vous faire voir non pas
avec la date que j'ai fait guère mais
avec une date que j'ai fait il ya quinze
jours j'étais au festival facéties avec
marine accueille et les lots j e j logis
avec les filles je vous met uniquement
les images dont j'ai les droits par
contre et c'est bien la fin de la vidéo
puisque après j'ai aussi deux trois
questions à vous poser par rapport à la
suite des vidéos de cette semaine et de
la semaine prochaine votre avis compte
à quoi ressemble une journée de tourner
parce que là c'était vraiment une
journée je partais le matin et je
rentrais le soir
cerrone l'oiseau sait pas plus
on espère qu'ils seront plus de 10 parce
que sinon ça peut se voir dans la salle
la coupe d'été
et ça ce sondage joachim tard champ on
ne te voit plus
ça c'est le tour bus pour la tournée de
rodage ou ou pas en fait
oui
google
oh
devoir changer
bon alors un goût
mais dis donc tu es un cac les abonnés
la meuse la meurthe que tu vas peut
demain et pendant ce temps là sur la
scène
et
la deuxième partie j'espère que cette
vidéo un petit peu différente vous aura
plu on est en milieu de semaine comme ça
c'est pas un truc ou faux trop réfléchir
je me disais que ça pouvait être
intéressant
ben si ça vous a plu vous mettez un
pouce en l'air sous la vidéo et voilà
alors j'avais quand même deux trois
petites choses à vous dire et surtout à
vous demander je sais pas si vous avez
regardé la vidéo d'hier j'annonce que je
fais une vidéo participative avec vous
ça se passe sur mon facebook ma fan page
facebook fabien olicard l'idée c'est que
vous m'envoyez un my maps regarder dans
la vidéo d'hier tout expliqué compris
dans le descriptif
là j'en ai déjà reçu pas mal ils sont
vraiment cool mais ils sont hyper
sérieux si vous voulez envoyer un my
maps décalé sur un sujet de complètement
what the fuck c'est complètement
possible
et puis ça pourrait être cool aussi pour
la vidéo pour l'instant on est sur des
trucs plutôt carré en faisant cette
vidéo aujourd'hui un petit peu plus
légère pour vous laisser le temps de
respirer je me suis dit tiens il serait
peut-être temps de relancer aussi des
formats qui m'avait beaucoup plu de
faire le trou story quand je vous
raconter une anecdote de vie même si sur
certaines anecdotes je te lire les
commentaires aujourd'hui et marquer na
c'est un gros mytho c'est n'importe quoi
pas de problème est aussi un format que
j'avais fait que trois fois c'était
mentaliser l'un d'entre vous par skype
et j'ai bien envie de refaire ces deux
choses là alors vous me dites dans les
commentaires déjà si ça vous tente et
lequel vous voulez un premier temps que
vous êtes là je le dis le meet up avance
bien
il avance très très bien je voulais
aller dans un endroit spécifique et j'ai
une opportunité de ouf je vous le dirai
très bientôt
mais ce sera début octobre à paris ne
savait pas prévu de le dire dans la
vidéo mais comme ça vous le savez pensez
à vous abonner avant de partir et rendez
vous demain à 17 heures puisque le
mental blog c c'est c'est tout ça allez
ciao
je joue mon spectacle en entier le 23
septembre à la garenne colombes c'est la
date la plus proche de paris si jamais
vous voulez venir sinon il ya toutes les
dates de tournée sur mon cycle